king 28 followed by h5 to secure the
knight
reshuffling the knight 97 knight g6 pawn
to h6 to cover this square bishop d7
intending to put the king on c8 pawn to
b6 intending to play bishop b7 putting
the king here all of these things have
been debated heavily and tend to work
pretty alright
therefore
it's a lot of choices to make and hikaru
decides today he doesn't want this and
bravely decides to sacrifice a bishop
as he has done in at least
20 i would have to count but i would
guess he's had the position at least 20
times from either side knight takes b5
pawn to a4
and now i think they're done with the
thinking and
the game
that and then i might have indicated
earlier will will now unfold
um
at faster speed yeah and there was a
question earlier uh
from from bonnie hopper why are they
resident slippering are they both
qualified and i assume if bunny doesn't
know there are more people in chat who
might not know uh hikaru has qualified
for the candidates and wesley has no
chance of qualifying for the candidates
so
there really isn't very much at stake as
as regards the sort of the broader
picture of the grand prix they're only
playing for
uh money and prestige here and uh
clearly tough decision for both of them
to go for this line i mean they clearly
wrestled with it
but
here we are i hope the spectators in
berlin on this sunny sunday
did enjoy
the action okay we all knew this was
going to happen and
the
the talk before the show was more or
less if today is going to be a 15-minute
show or a 30-minute show and we get to
almost 30 so
what's not to like